Thanks so much for, uh, for having me. Um,
if the theme of the session
is a cops and nerds,
I think I'm going to force the audience
to guess which of those I am. Um,
so here's what I wanted to talk about.
Thanks so much for having me.
What I wanted to talk about
is, um, you know, you realize,
especially when you live
in a big city like Chicago,
how many heartbreaking social problems,
uh,
that we are trying to solve right now.
And you also realize that
we are increasingly living
in a world of, uh, of data,
of big data.
And so it seems like there's a very
natural and easy intellectual arbitrage
opportunity where we can take this
sort of machine learning tools that we
encounter all the time in the commercial
sector and just kind of plugin,
plugin play and apply them
self policy problems. Uh, it's,
it looks like an easy
intellectual arbitrage
opportunity for making the world a
better place. And so what I wanted
to do is I wanted to talk about, um,
how I think social progress on some of
these really difficult policy problems is
going to require a lot more, I think,
than just off the shelf machine learning.
So that's the, the theme of
the, the theme of the talk.
So let me talk about that. Um, uh,
a little bit more concretely
within the context of, uh,
one particularly important problem
that we have here in Chicago.
But this is obviously not just a Chicago
problem. So if you're hearing Chicago,
you drive down to 26th and California
on the southwest side of the city,
you will see the Cook County
jail, uh, which has, you know,
depending on the day between six
or eight or 10,000 residents,
some of the most economically
disadvantaged people in
the city of Chicago, uh,
80 to 90% of whom are either
African American or Hispanic.
So we can back up and say,
how did we wind up with so many
people in the Cook County jail?
So here's a little bit,
a little primmer on how the
criminal justice system works.
So you get arrested in the United States
and the constitution says within 48
hours,
you've got to go in front of a judge who
makes the decision about where you're
going to await adjudication of your case.
Do you get to go home or do you have to
sit in jail waiting for your case to be
resolved? And, um,
the law says that the judge is
supposed to make that decision,
not based on whether you're guilty or
not or what the punishment is for the
crime that you were
alleged to have committed.
But the law says the judge is supposed
to make that decision entirely based on a
prediction,
a prediction of your safety risk,
and a prediction of your
flight risk. And, uh,
this is an enormously consequential
decision as you can imagine.
So if the judge gels you, uh, on average,
you'll spend two to four months in
a place like the Cook County jail.
You could imagine what that
does to your, uh, job prospects.
You can imagine what that
does to your family. Uh,
you can imagine what that to the
local county, a budget to keep six,
eight,
10,000 people in jail,
releasing people also has a
serious downside risk as well.
Uh,
the person that the judge releases might
go on to commit another crime and crime
itself is also very
regressive in its impact.
So super high stakes decision.
Uh, if you're a tech person,
you look at this and say,
well,
what is the criminal justice system
currently doing to help judges make this
high stakes? Very difficult prediction.
And this is status quo in most cities.
This is the same technology that we
would have used in the 1950s or maybe the
1850s ye olde, um, decision aid. Um,
and so it's natural to
think, well, you know,
why not instead use this sort
of technology that places
like Google are applying
to all sorts of commercial applications.
And so this seems like
super straight forward, uh,
because it seems like we have most of
the important ingredients that we need to
make progress. So for starters, we have
these amazing machine learning tools.
And I think it's, it's easy
because they're so ubiquitous now,
it's easy to overlook exactly
how amazing these tools are.
So let me just spend a minute reminding
us of this within the context of one
very common kind of machine learning
application, which is sentiment analysis.
So if you're a computer scientist,
you know,
one of the canonical
applications of machine learning
is to take a piece of text
that a author is a human,
is written and try and infer what the
effect was that the author is trying to
communicate.
So here's a example from a more or less
randomly selected a consumer product off
of Amazon,
the Hustler five 71 banana slicer.
And so what we have here is
a product review, some text,
and then we also have a starred review,
which gives us sort of ground truth.
What actually was the author intending?
And so here's an example.
This is from someone named thrifty.
He who says,
I bought this in order to speed up
cutting up a banana for my cereal.
And a time that I saved in that endeavor
was spent cleaning this implement.
It's not easy to clean.
You have to scrub between every
rung to thoroughly clean it.
You can see that's it's not a great
review. Two out of five stars.
You can look at another one
by uncle pooky who says,
once I figured out I had to peel the
banana before using it works much better.
Ordering one for my nephew who's in the
air force in California and he's been
using an old slinky to slice.
He's been in as he should really enjoy
this product. Five out of five stars,
a confusing by Qtip.
There's no way to tell if this is
a standard or metric banana slicer.
Additional markings
audit would help greatly.
One out of five stars and finally
from Jay Anderson Angle is wrong.
I tried the banana slicer and found that
unacceptable as shown in the picture of
the slices is curved from left to right.
All of my bananas are bent the other way,
so this is an example also of how
machine learning turns out to have such
powerful commercial applications.
This helped a hustler company figure out
what their five 72 banana slicer should
look like. No. Here's, I think the
sort of the key lesson from this is,
you know,
you're reading these narrative reviews
and it is super easy for you to figure
out what the author was intending.
And it's so easy that, you know,
when the computer scientist in the
middle of the 20th century were initially
working on artificial intelligence,
this led to a natural sort of conclusion
about how you would try and get a
computer to do what humans do,
especially for something
that is so easy for us to do,
which is just program them to
do something, how we do it.
Um, so introspect on what you do and
write a program that does exactly the same
thing. And here's sort of the problem
with that kind of approach, uh, that,
that the computer scientists
found in practice.
This is from a study done at Cornell
doing sentiment analysis for a movie
review.
So they get a bunch of Cornell nerds in
the basement to introspect on what words
they would think would show up in a
positive or negative movie review.
They write a program that looks for those
words and then they classify positive
or negative reviews on that basis.
Usually we set up the test set here
so that we have 50% positive reviews,
50% negative reviews.
So accuracy of 50% would
be like random guessing.
And so these are the words that the
Cornell nerds, um, picked. Uh, I dunno,
why suck. And sucks are both
separate words there. It's Cornell,
not the University of Chicago.
So one of my coauthors is from Cornell.
So I see that with, uh, with love. Um,
and so here's what we saw with this sort
of programming approach is, you know,
we're doing better than random guessing,
but not much better than random guessing.
Not much better than random guessing.
And the breakthrough here with these
machine learning tools came from when the
computer scientists realized that we
just need to forget that we do these,
that we know how to do these things,
treat the known like the unknown,
and just start treating this like a brute
force empirical exercise and basically
mined the data.
Mine dumb movie reviews themselves for
information about what words turn up more
frequently in positive and
negative reviews. And um, you know,
once we start doing that,
we start to get up to 90 a accuracy
rates on the order of like 95%.
So this really was the big breakthrough
and the tools that enable us to do this
really are incredibly amazing.
I think what's also particularly exciting
from a public policy perspective,
if you think about like pretrial release
decisions is that there is an enormous
amount of data to be had. So this is what
we discovered when we were working, uh,
building a pretrial risk prediction
tool ourselves using data from a large
anonymous American city of eight
and a half million people. Um,
and you know, you have millions
and millions of observations,
which doesn't sound like a lot when
you're talking to an audience at Google.
But I think in a policy
environment, uh, this is, you know,
this is a new development to have so much
information that we can bring to bear
on these problems and for each
case goes through bond court.
We have lots of information about the
current charge and their prior criminal
record. So lots of information
that can be brought to bear.
And these machine learning tools
now are increasingly accessible.
So anybody with an Internet connection
can download our free software and just
basically build a machine learning
algorithm and they're off to the races.
Now normally in a machine
learning exercise,
the final step is also easy,
which is determining how good of a job
your algorithm is actually doing. Right.
And so imagine that I'm doing some sort
of commercial application of machine
learning and I am trying to decide
like how good is my facial recognition
software doing.
And I wanted give it a bunch of new face
pictures that it hasn't seen and I want
it to tell me if a normal human faces
in the picture. And so you know,
you can look at that face, no face. It's
easy to tell and score the algorithm,
you know.
Uh,
I think one of the things I learned to
do it for this slide show is huskies have
the funniest dog faces.
Um,
and whether this one is a normal
human face I think is sort of a deeper
philosophical question.
But this is easy, right?
This is the easy part.
This turns out to be the first point in
policy applications where you realize
that this is very different
from commercial, from
commercial machine learning.
And part of the issue here is that
we really, at some fundamental level,
we really don't care
about prediction quality.
The thing that we really care
about instead is decision quality.
What I want to know is can I take a
machine learning algorithm and build some
new release rule that I can give to a
judge and we'll let actually turn into the
world becoming a better place.
Now, why is that complicated? Okay.
Why is that complicated? Think
about, um, how an algorithm,
an algorithmic release role could
potentially make the world a better place.
The algorithm might want to detain someone
that the judge releases or it might
want to release someone
that the judge to teens.
And so then we can ask ourselves,
how do we score whether the algorithmic
release rule is better than the judge or
not in a world in which the data that
we have available to us to evaluate the
algorithm is generated by
the human decisions generated
by the judge's decisions.
And so here's what the issue is, right?
If the judge releases a defendant,
right? If the judge releases a defendant,
we don't have any sort of problem,
I can observe what the crime outcome
is under the judge's actual decision.
And I know what the crime outcome is
under the counterfactual algorithmic
decision.
If the algorithm wants to detain the
defendant because putting someone in jail
by definition incapacitates them
and prevents them from Aig, uh,
engaging in crime.
So that's easy.
But what if the judge
detains the defendant, right?
What if the judge detains the defendant
and the Algorithm wants to release them?
How do I, whether the algorithm is
right or whether the judge was right.
Okay. Now if you're a computer scientist,
you look at this and say, well,
this doesn't feel like a hard problem,
right?
At some level it doesn't
feel like a hard problem.
We have a bunch of data on the
people who the judge released.
We have a bunch of background information
on the people that the judge released
and the judge detained.
Why don't we just assume that the
crime outcomes for the people the judge
released would be like a crime outcomes
for the people the judge detained who
have observably similar current
Arestin prior criminal record, right.
It seems like a very, very straightforward
imputation exercise on its face.
Here's the problem and
a policy application,
which is the judge sees things
that no algorithm will ever see.
So this is a,
this is an example of um,
this is an example of a
defendant, uh, mid 20,
it's called it a 25 year
old guy who report reported
as a occupation when he was
arrested as tattoo model. I didn't
know there was such a thing. Uh,
he gets arrested two different times,
uh,
one time that's him on the left. Uh,
and then this is him again on the right.
So you'll notice that the 25 year old
tattoo model on the right has decided that
it was a good idea to get his
face tattooed. Like joker,
the Super Villain from
the dark knight moving,
but you can't see because it's on the
other side of the face is on this side.
You can see he's got the joker
tattooed on a, on his right,
on his left it says,
just in case there was any ambiguity
about what he's about on his left,
it says in giant letters.
Fuck Batman.
Now to the Algorithm,
the 25 year old tattoo model on the left
and the 25 year old tattoo model on the
right look exactly the same. The Algorithm
looks at the guy in the left and say,
he doesn't look no prior record,
current offenses and misdemeanor.
This does not look like
a very high risk guy.
The judge sees that can see
something extra about the defendant.
Now imagine what happens.
The algorithm goes to the judge and says,
why are you detaining these
25 year old tattoo models?
These are all low risk guys.
You should just let them go.
You look the guy on the right go and
crime goes up by a lot more than the
algorithm had anticipated and we wind up
inadvertently making the world a worse
place while other than a better place.
Okay,
and the key here is that
in these sorts of social,
social science or policy applications,
we have to take seriously the possibility
that the judge has private information
that the algorithm doesn't have,
which makes this evaluation
problem enormously difficult.
And if we ignore that evaluation problem
when we're comparing the algorithm to
the judge where basically stacking the
deck in favor of saying the algorithm,
the algorithm almost has to
do better than the judge.
If you ignore the possibility that
the judge has as extra information.
Okay.
So what is the solution to a,
what is the solution to
that problem? Well, um,
the solution to that problem starts,
has two comes from two insights.
The first insight is to recognize
that the problems one sided.
So when the Algorithm wants to release
a GL defendant, that's a problem.
But there's no problem if the algorithm,
if the algorithmic decision rule
wants to jail someone that the,
the judge released.
And the second insight is to rely on a
common trick that we have in econometrics
or the causal inference literature,
which takes advantage of the fact that
in this case we have something like
random assignment of cases to judges.
So what we wind up having his multiple
judges seeing case loads of defendants
that are similar on average.
And yet the judges differ a lot with
respect to their leniency rates.
And so here's what we can do in that case,
here's what we can do in that case.
So imagine that we have two judges,
one of them with the 90% release rate
and one of them with an 80% release rate
and they're seeing case loads
that are similar on average.
And so here on the left we've got
the judge with the 90% release rate,
we can go into the pool,
the remaining 90% of defendants that the
lenient judge has released and weekend
rank order defendants by our algorithms,
predictions of their crime risk.
And then weekend countdown,
that rank ordered list of defendants by
predicted risk and pick another 10% of
defendants to detain.
So this is what the Algorithm's guests
is for the most socially productive
marginal 10% of defendants to detain.
And then when we can do,
and that gets us down effectively
to an 80% release rate.
And then what we can do in that case is
compare the crime rate that we get in
that case with the actual crime rate
that we get from the 80% released judge.
Right.
And that turns out to be a credible way
and a fair way to compare whether the
algorithm really is doing a better job
than than the judge and what you see when
you do that.
So that,
so when you see when you do that is it
is indeed the case that the algorithm is
doing better than the judge and the
algorithm is doing a lot better than the
judge.
And so what you can see is if we were
to hold the size of the jail population
constant and just use the algorithmic
release role to decide who to detain,
we could reduce crime rates by 25%
without having the change of the jail
population.
Now you might be sitting there thinking,
given that we've ramped
up the incarceration papa
population in the United
States so much,
maybe you think the big problem in the
United States now is not crime so much as
incarceration itself. And
so alternatively, what you
can imagine doing is saying,
let's hold the crime rate constant.
How many fewer people do we need to detain
in order to achieve the same level of
crime reduction as the judges
current decisions achieve.
And if you do that,
we can reduce the jail population by
fully 42% with no increase in crime right
now.
That's completely amazing.
That's completely amazing part because
if you think about how hard these social
problems are to solve,
usually in those rare cases where
we find an effective solution,
they turn out to be either very expensive
to implement or very difficult to
scale up successfully. That's not the
case with the machine learning algorithm.
Once the thing is built,
the marginal cost of running this
over and over again is near zero.
And because it's an automated tool,
it scales nearly perfectly at least over
the range that we have for something
like pretrial release decisions.
Um,
there is something that you'd be
worried about, which is, you know,
we don't care just about crime
and a detention outcomes,
especially in the criminal justice system.
We care a lot about things
like fairness as well.
And so maybe what's also amazing about
the machine learning application in this
case is in addition to the enabling us
to simultaneously reduce crime and jail
populations,
at the same time,
we can also reduce disparities within
the detention populations as well.
And the answer to that is easy to see
why the algorithm can do that as easy to
see once you recognize what the
alternative to the algorithm is,
which is the same human decisions that
gave us the current criminal justice
system that is so skewed in the direction
of over representing racial minorities
and low income populations,
uh, behind bars. Okay.
Now if we were in a,
if we were in a commercial setting,
you would build an algorithm like
this. You have your face detector, uh,
software, you'd put it on a phone
and you'd be off to the races.
The social benefits of the algorithm
would be automatically realized. Um,
if you sort of think about the
pretrial release application,
there's another backend step,
right? There's another backend step,
which is that nobody imagines that the
algorithm is actually ever going to be
the decision maker. Instead,
we imagine, so realistically,
the Algorithm for predicting defendant
risk is inevitably just going to be a
decision aid for a human being that
then has to translate the algorithms
predictions into decisions. And if the
human being is getting things wrong,
they can undo whatever the social
good potential is for the algorithm
algorithms, predictions
to achieve. Okay. Um,
and so, you know, put differently,
the robot in this case is not
going to replace the human,
we think of the robot as a compliment,
not substitute for a human
judgment at the end of the day.
So here's one final, I think
really interesting, uh, uh,
application or potential application of
machine learning that I think looks very
different from what we're used to seeing
in, uh, in the commercial setting.
And that is to basically use machine
learning is a behavioral diagnostic to
better understand what the human
beings themselves are doing right now,
partly as a way to help solve this problem
of how we optimally combine human and
machine intelligence in
designing a decision aid that
we can give the judges and
realize the potential for social good.
So you know, normally what we do,
normally what we do is we take
a machine learning algorithm,
we predict the defendant's risk,
we do a horse race between
the algorithm and the judge.
So the defendant's behavior
is the object of interest.
The other thing that we can do is
basically turn the algorithm on the judge
themselves.
That is basically predict what the
judge is going to do in a given case.
But the judge is going to do as a function
of the defendant's characteristics.
Okay.
And that turns out to give us lots of
really interesting insights into what
humans are doing.
So let me just give you a couple,
a couple of quick examples of that.
So one thing,
notice what this lets us do for starters.
So if you look at the
actual judge decisions,
you know the only thing that you observed
from judges is whether they detain or
release a defendant,
right?
But if you think about our
prediction of the judge's behavior,
that's a continuous release
probability at that point.
And what we can do then is we can look
across the defendant risk distribution to
see where judges are at least certain.
Okay. And you can see in this graph here,
what we've done is we have the judges
predicted released probability on the y
axis here and on the x axis,
uh,
sorry,
the judges detained probability predicted
detain power probability on the exit
on the y axis. And then what we've
done is we've been defending,
so we've grouped defendants together based
on the algorithms predicted defendant
crime risk.
Okay.
So we're looking at the dispersion of
judges release probabilities as a function
of how serious the defendant's
crime risk actually is.
And what you can see here is it's really
the highest risk defendants that are
the ones where the judges have the most
uncertainty and the most difficulty
making decisions.
And it's not,
it's not inevitable that that's what
we would have seen. So for instance,
if you look at like
education applications,
what you see is that
principals do amazingly well
at predicting which teachers
are amazingly good and amazingly bad.
And principles have a huge difficulty
distinguishing the quality of all the
teachers in the middle,
right?
So it didn't need to turn out
like this in the crime setting.
It does turn out though that the judge,
it turns out to be the case that the
judges seem to have the most difficulty
with the highest risk cases.
And one of the things that we're learning
from psychology is that judges have
very constrained judges.
Like all human beings have
very constrained bandwidth
for judgment and decision
making.
And so one of the things for starters we
can use this information about is sort
of a bandwidth triage tool for judges.
Here are the cases where you
need to devote extra time
and being expert shore in
mapping the algorithms
predictions into a decision,
we know that these are going to be the
cases that are hardest for you. Um,
okay. And let me give you one more.
Uh, one more example of this is,
uh,
the other thing that we can do then is
we can look at the crime and detention
outcomes of the actual judge decisions
versus the predicted judge to decisions.
So if you think about what the
predicted judge decisions are,
this is for a case with a
given set of characteristics.
What does the judge do you on average?
And how does the average judge do compared
to the actual judge decisions that
very around that, that average, okay,
now economists would look
at this and say it's clear.
It's clear that the actual judge decisions
have to do better because the judge
has more information.
The actual judge has more information
than the algorithm because the judge sees
more things than the algorithm sees.
A psychologists look at this and say it's
not obvious. We know that, uh, judges,
there can be a lot of
noise in the system too,
and the extra information the judges have.
And so what we actually see in the data
is that the predicted judge that is the
inflammation reduced version of the judge
winds up leading do better crime and
detention outcomes than the actual judge.
Okay.
Now why might that be,
um,
did you judges Miss Miss Predict?
Um, let me just tell you a,
uh, a quick story about what I
think might be going on here.
Um, and it's a, uh,
it's a story that comes from
a conversation that I had
with a friend of mine who
is an emergency room doctor.
And he was like the attending resident
one night in the Er that he's working in
and a patient comes in complaining of
signs that look like he's having a heart
attack.
And so this is a common situation that
they have in the Er and the Er docs.
In that case,
their key goal is to try and predict
whether the patient is actually having a
heart attack or not. And if they are,
then they send them to the ICU for a,
for immediate treatment.
And so the, uh, you know,
everybody else on the team, they go in,
they do this sort of cardiac enzyme test,
uh, to as part of the prediction.
And if it's above some sort of level,
then that's sort of one diagnostic.
And so they, uh, they do that.
And then my friend goes to the, sort
of, the doctor and nurse's station says,
what do we have here? And everybody
at the station says, you know,
we've got this guy, he's got chest pains,
we administered the cardiac enzyme test.
It's above the threshold level,
a lot above the threshold level.
We got to get this guy
into the ICU immediately.
So then my friend goes
in to see the guy in, uh,
in the waiting room and the guy
sitting there and he looks up at, um,
at my friend, the guy sitting there
eating a snack. He's having this,
a slice of watermelon and he's talking
to my friend and my friend's like,
what's going on? And the guy's like,
yeah, I'm having some chest pains.
I don't feel great. My friend talks
to him for a couple of minutes,
goes back out to the,
uh,
to the station and everyone's
like, okay, we're ready to go,
right? We're going to get this guy up to
the ICU. And my friend says, uh, no, I,
I, you know, I think he's all right. I
talked to him, he's pretty chill. Uh,
I'm not worried about it. And
everybody else is like, no, no, no.
We got to get them to the
ICU. And my friend says, look,
I'm the only one who actually
saw the patient in person.
You guys have just seen his medical
test results. And I'm telling you,
like I talked to the guy, he's hanging
out, he's having a snack. There's,
there's no big deal.
15 minutes later the guy goes into cardiac
arrest and they race them to the ICU.
I think what's going on there,
what's going on there is, you know,
the human brain is designed to be
sensitive to very salient information,
even if it's irrelevant.
We don't normally associate having a
snack with having a major health disorder.
Right.
And so you can see how my friend,
like the fact of having the snack was
an enormously salient detail that turned
out to be totally irrelevant.
Um,
I think the data that we're seeing are
consistent with lots of things like that
distracting judges in the
court setting as well. Right.
And so the key goal for realizing the
social potential of these tools is going
to be to figure out what exactly
those salient but irrelevant pieces of
information are that are
leading the judges stray.
That is not a computer science problem,
right?
In some sense that's kind of like the
last mile problem of building these
algorithms and helping judges and that
last mile problem is not a computer
science problem. That's really
a behavioral science problem.
So as I sort of look at what
is, um, if I sort of look at,
I'm sorry, the other thing to say is, you
know, I'm using bail as an example here,
but nothing that I've said
is unique to bill, right?
There are tons and tons of super important
policy decisions that policymakers
and private citizens make every day with
really important policy consequences
that hinge on a prediction where the
person themselves are currently making the
prediction. But in principle we could
be doing that with data and stead,
you know what college major or
course is best for me in college,
students are millions of college students
are trying to answer that every year.
How long am I going to be unemployed is
I'm trying to think about how much to
scale back my consumption or where to
set my reservation quality for some new
job offer that I should be taking or not,
or how much house can I afford?
What's going to happen to my
income stream over the future? Um,
behavioral science tells us that
these are prediction problems.
They're going to be hugely difficult for
us. So what does this teach us? Well,
I think one thing that we can see is
that prediction can be super useful for
making progress on these policy
problems. Um, at the same time,
there are potential pitfalls.
Now I think what is really
important about this,
what's really important about this is
that we know that there are, so it's,
what's not news is that there are
pitfalls in applying machine learning to
policy problems,
right?
There are probably 10,000 papers and
computer science published about,
for instance, fairness. Okay.
I am reasonably optimistic that the
field will eventually solve that sort of
problem because we recognize it
and so many people are devoting,
understandably inappropriately devoting
so much energy to solving that problem.
What worries me about this is that there
are lots of other challenges here that
are not even on anybody's radar screen
and that could lead us to inadvertently
take these tools,
import them into a policy setting and
accidentally make things worse rather than
better. And I think the solution
to those sorts of problems,
they're not really about
machine learning engineering.
I think progress on those
sorts of problems really
are going to require taking
these amazing machine learning walls
and combining them with insights from
social science and behavioral science.
And I think the,
the payoff to getting that
right is potentially enormous
positive social impact.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
uh,
you mentioned that you do things or you're
able to do things like reduce racial
disparities and um,
in bail setting and things like that.
And I can understand where,
um,
there's been obviously a lot
of consternation about, uh,
accidentally in coding
demographic characteristics
into the Dataset that didn't
otherwise express them.
But there may be a high correlation and
so you could say a low income area is
higher likelihood of missing bail,
therefore imputed flight risk.
So can you comment on how you are,
how those things get controlled for and
how that I understand the human bias
element obviously,
and snap judgments can,
on the one hand it's
probably a very bad thing.
I think it's less well understood how a
ml can be made to be more fair in a way
that explicitly excludes a sort
of inadvertent characteristics.
Yeah, yeah, it's a great, um, it's a
great question. You know, I think that,
um, one of the, uh,
I think one of the,
uh,
challenges in,
in my mind in taking these tools and
applying them to policy settings now is
that there is a wedge between,
uh,
what I think the statistics
would tell us about what it,
what promotes fairness and the way
that our current legal structures,
which were built around dealing with
human predictions. And decisions allow.
And so I might turn your
question and turn on,
turn it on its head just a little bit,
which is to say isn't necessarily,
so if a human being is making something
like a hiring decision or a jail
decision,
you would say we ideally would have
that info that human being completely
blinded to defendant race or job
applicant race. Like for sure that's true.
I think it's less self evident that
that is true for the algorithm. Right.
And I think part of the reason for that
is because like unlike a human being,
the algorithm has no preferences and
has no capacity for implicit bias.
The way that the human brain does the
algorithm really is like a dog that chases
the car that you tell it to chase.
Like it's just very narrowly monomaniacal.
Right.
And sort of imagine, let me give you a
stylized example to highlight what I mean.
Right.
So imagine that we're living in a city
where the rate at which you know whites
and minorities engage in crime, that
true offending rate is exactly the same.
Okay. Suppose assist the city
is 50% white, 50% minority.
Suppose that the police never make a
false arrest to a white city resident,
but that half the arrests to
minorities are false arrests, right,
and the chances that you get arrested
if you actually engage in crime at the
same for whites and minorities,
right?
If I take that Dataset and I give it
to an algorithm that's blinded to race,
what's the algorithm going to do?
The algorithm has no choice but to assume
that each additional arrest on your
rap sheet.
Suppose that I'm predicting an outcome
like failure to appear in court and for
the moment, let's assume that
that's not susceptible to bias.
We can have a separate
conversation about that,
but just suppose that we're willing to
assume that the outcome itself is not
susceptible to buy us, right? If the
algorithm is, is blinded to race,
it has no choice but to assume each arrest
on your rap sheet is exactly the same,
no matter who you are and what's gonna
wind up happening in that case is that
African Americans on average, you're
going to have much higher predicted.
Failure to appear risk than whites.
And if judges are instructed by the law
to make detention decisions based on a
failure to appear of risk,
we're going to increase incarceration
for minorities relative to whites.
But now notice what happens if I use
a machine learning algorithm that has
access to race and is allowed to
search or mine the data for evidence of
interactivity between the predictors.
What the algorithm does and that case
is it would immediately recognize that
each additional arrest for a white has
twice as much signal as each additional
arrest for a minority in this city,
uh,
for risk of FTA. And in that case,
if you sort of think about it,
a little linear regression,
in that case,
the slope will be half as large for
African Americans as for whites.
And a average predicted risk in this
scenario will wind up being exactly the
same for whites versus minorities with
only with the algorithm that has access
to race.
No,
I was at a national academy of Science's
panel last fall were a question like
this came up and every computer scientist,
social scientist,
data scientist in the room,
it was like,
for sure we need to think about ways
of letting the algorithm, you know,
thinking about the conditions under
which the algorithm should have access to
race because it can in some circumstances
promote fairness and every lawyer in
the room,
just one completely bananas and you can
see exactly why the lawyers have that
view.
And so I think this is an example where
like the technology is outrunning the
legal structures and I think that we're
gonna, this is gonna have to be a big,
a big area that we're going to need to
think about resolving in the future as
these sorts of algorithms become baked
into our policy systems more and more.
Great.
Joe,
thanks for coming in. This is awesome. Uh,
you talked earlier about adjusting the
algorithm to choose between either crime
rate or release rate,
and is it truly just one of the others
there way to kind of balance both of them?
Oh yeah. Sorry. So let me, um, uh,
I should've given you a better graph
for this. One way to think about this.
As you can imagine like a,
a two dimensional space where you have
crime rate on one axis of the detention
rate on the other axis and the judges
current decision is a point in that space,
right?
And what the Algorithm let's you do the
algorithm winds up predicting crime risk
much more accurately than the judge.
And so the algorithm let's
you have lots of both,
lots of one without increasing the like
less of one holding the other one fixed
door.
So you have a range of options that you
can choose from in terms of how you want
to realize those gains,
right?
So one extreme is I hold the
jail population constant.
I take all of the gain in
the form of reduced crime.
The other extreme is I take
the crime rate constant. I,
I realize all of the game from reduced
jail or I can pick any point in between
there and get some of both.
And where you fall on that potential
outcome space is entirely a policy
decision. Not a, not a social
science or computer science decision.
Thank you.
Hey, so are you doing, uh,
I'm one of those engineers,
computer scientists who is going
bananas, right? Because there,
there are a ton of concerns here.
Oh.
And I've worked on machine learning
models and we know that the data makes a
difference, right? The data
that we're ingesting. Yup.
It's pretty easy to beat,
I think Chicago rates around racism,
right?
You're on racist decisions around
socioeconomic status, et Cetera. Right?
I mean, Chicago is when the most
racist segregated places there are.
And maybe it's because I grew up a
few blocks from that jail, right.
Just seen it over and over and over again.
Right?
So the fact that the academy that the
algorithm can beat Chicago and Cook County
judge rates is, um, it's
great to see, right?
And it's great that we're making
better progress. But in and of itself,
I don't think actually says that the
algorithm is the way we should go. Right.
There's other human factors that
have to be taken account. Yep.
So part of it is yes,
the data is messy because we have
so much embedded systemic racism.
And the last people I want to turn more
data to is the Chicago cops because of
everything that they do in the
city to our communities. Right. Uh,
so there's a lot of danger at play in how
we use the data and you just mentioned
as well.
Um,
and answer to the previous question is
taking into account the demographics are
not.
And we know from Kathy O'malley,
he spoke from the weapons
of math destruction book,
right. That we, you know,
whether it's credit card rates, there's
other ways to proxy race, right.
That end up also embedding the same
conditions that led to this situation
throughout. So I don't want to make a, I
understand that we can do a lot better.
Right.
And the algorithm could do better by also,
I definitely want to challenge the
dichotomy that says the algorithm and the
technology in and of itself.
Yes.
Better without taking into account
all the other embedded, uh,
yeah, concern. Here's the,
here's the what. So it's a
very fair question. Um, or, uh,
here's a way that I would, I would
sort of think about it is, um,
I think of the role as a,
of people like me and people like you,
the other people in the,
in the room is to, um,
build tools and honestly and accurately
describe what they're capable of doing.
A and in a policy set, you
know, in a commercial setting,
you build these tools and then if you
think they can, they can make money.
You deploy them and if they're successful,
they keep going.
And if they're not successful,
they get scrapped. Right?
In the policy setting it's different.
It's not my decision or you just,
your decision to make,
it's like some larger collective society,
societal decision about whether we
want to use these tools are not.
And I think in this case it really is a,
um,
I think it is something, it is a question
that is not easily dismissed, right?
So I come to you and say,
I have a policy,
let's call it a black box black
box policy for the moment, right?
I have a jail system that is 90% minority
in this large anonymous city of eight
and a half million people
that were using the data from,
I can assure you that the city population
is not anywhere near 90% minority.
Okay.
I've got a black box policy got can
reduce the size of the jail population by
42% right?
Suppose for the moment we can get
judges to follow the algorithmic
recommendations perfectly or
the black box ballsy record.
I've got a policy lever that lets
you reduce the size of the pot,
the jail by 42% who benefits massively
from a 42% reduction in the jail
population in a world in which the
jail population is 90% minority.
90% of the people that the
algorithm that the black box policy,
in that case we're doing releases,
so benefit from this are minorities.
Right?
And then on top of that
we can disproportionately
further reduce the racial
composition of the jail. Now it is
true that you can look at that and say,
yeah, but the algorithms not
perfect because it's still
relying on data that have
baked in biases. Those are the same
data that we would hand to the judge.
I think the flip side is the alternative
is the judge using exactly the same
bias data in the current status quo system
that gives us a jail population that
is much, much larger and has a higher
chair my than it currently has.
And I feel like this is one
where reasonable people can
argue both sides of this.
And to me it's not,
it's not a crazy position to say,
I will capitalize on the fairness
gains that I have in front of me,
which is the 43% reduction in the jail
and a reduction in a share minority by 10
percentage point.
Thank you. Yep. Time for
one more question. Um, yeah,
I had a question around also kind of
we're using data around the police and
things like that.
So are there projects that you're doing
to analyze a ras and like the geographic
breakdown,
it was racial breakdowns of things like
that that the police are doing versus
you know, kind of continuing this kind of
work. But just on the opposite side. Um,
and then also,
I think you may have touched on it,
but how you're using this ml model
in real time with judges and how,
what you've seen with that,
if that legal system is
somewhat open to these tools,
just to speak a little bit
more on that if you could.
Yeah, yeah. I think, um, the, uh,
for the, um, uh,
let me take the second
question for starters.
So we are working with a large American
anonymous city of eight and a half
million people to think about whether
there are ways to actually, uh, you know,
so the tool that I, the results
that I described so far, you know,
we did that as an academic study
as a kind of proof of concept.
And the large anonymous cities
said, uh, their policy decision,
or you might disagree with it,
but there are policy decision was if we
could really reduce our jail population
by 42% without increasing crime,
that's something that we want to do.
And that's something that we view as
a step towards promoting fairness.
And so we're working with them
now to build this thing. Um,
we're seeing sort of similarly encouraging
results in terms of the predictive
accuracy.
I think the frontier science problem that
we're encountering is how do you give
this to the judges in a way where
they're able to learn their comparative
advantage versus when the Algorithm
has the comparative advantage in an
environment in which,
right now there's not much feedback.
And so we need to build a
bunch of scaffolding around
what the judge is doing to
make sure that that risk tool itself
translates into real better decisions.
Thanks.
Well, thank you all for coming.
That concludes our talk.
Let's give you guys a round of applause.